so this is the last vlog I'm going to be
doing in this apartment I'm moving out
of here next week so say goodbye to the
beautiful brick wall that I love so much
also coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 59
nationally we've dealt with our share of
tragedies in recent months last October
hurricane sandy caused an estimated 70 1
billion dollars in damage to the East
Coast in December 2010 were shot and
killed at Sandy Hook elementary in
Connecticut in April two bombs were set
off at the Boston Marathon and just last
week a massive tornado literally
uprooted an Oklahoma town killing 24
internationally there are of course
tragedies beyond counting for some such
tragedies are a way of life a daily
affair for those who have experienced
the pain the residents at the Jersey
Shore the parents of the children and
Newtown the marathon runners who trained
and trained and were robbed in violence
of their triumphs there opens up beneath
them a new basement of feeling which
many of us cannot and hopefully will
never know
such pain in this country especially in
those relatively safe neighborhoods like
the one I grew up in must be alienated
I've never experienced intense suffering
never seeing death or had someone very
close to me died so by what language
could the victim communicate to me his
sorrow what responsibility do I have to
feel and what responsibility do I have
to feel the day-to-day suffering for
those in parts of the world to whom such
deep pain is not alienating but
inclusionary for a short time after
college I studied philosophy and I found
that the more I read the more reading
seemed insufficient I was studying
philosophy to figure out what to do and
ironically as the concept of truth
became increasingly murky to me how to
act became increasingly planned the only
thing really worth doing I found was
helping other people of course people
need help in a variety of ways in
Stardust Memories Woody Allen says
obviously
if you don't have enough to eat or
something that becomes a major problem
you she's become very clear-cut but what
happens if you're living in a more you
know more affluence aside and you're
lucky enough to not have to worry about
that let's say you're surviving so then
you problems become how can I fall in
love or why can't I fall in love more
accurately and um why do I age and die
and what meaning can my life possibly
have you know the issues become very
complex for you you know for a guy who
makes a lot of funny movies you're if
you're kind of a depressive you know
Alan is describing Maslow's hierarchy of
needs a hierarchical list of our human
needs often shown as a pyramid from our
most fundamental to our most complex
from our physiological needs of food and
shelter to our need of safety of French
self esteem and finally of
self-actualization our needs of
creativity and morale the idea is that
one cannot ascend the pyramid until the
needs of lower orders are satisfied as a
novelist and blogger as one with food
shelter safety self esteem friends
I aim to treat issues of
self-actualization for myself and others
that's what this vlog is but that's also
a choice it means that my experience in
its attempts at profundity will be holy
and necessarily different from mine this
is Shawn above the uncultured project
Shawn withdrew from grad school after
hearing a speech by dr. Jeffrey Sachs
about poverty he liquidated his savings
and left his life to start a project in
which he uses technology and the web to
bring those in need together with what
they need teaming up with various
organizations sean has provided clean
water to villages rebuilt a high school
destroyed by a cyclone provided
emergency relief in multiple disaster
areas and helped over 10,000 children
through long term health worker programs
I just returned from Bangladesh where
two major events happened first was the
garment factory collapse which killed
over 1,100 people also episodes of
Muslim extremist violence with over a
quarter million
Muslim extremists congregated in the
city there were clashes with security
forces in many
what I'm feeling right now our
Bangladeshis resilience to tragedy and
it's very hard to talk about this in a
way that doesn't romanticize the poor or
those suffering because in many respects
because they can handle it or they seem
to be handling it and I couldn't it
sometimes makes me feel like I should
put them on a pedestal for me I can
actually have a normal day and then I
could go to an H&M and and all of a
sudden I'm getting flashbacks of the
garment factory collapse or I can watch
a see a movie where people die and they
get flashbacks of the morgue where I saw
corpses from your Muslim extremists we
were in anxiety
I don't yeah let's not show them just
keep it on me Sean is living the
conclusion I came to a few years ago a
conclusion that I entertained in the
comfort of my largely painless existence
but one which I did not see through for
reasons of family vocation and cowardice
see what Maslow doesn't cover is whether
or not it's okay to ascend the hierarchy
of needs when just one other person with
whom you share the world lacks the
fundamentals of life for any need of a
lower order when people ask me I tell
them that I'm a writer because I feel I
have a knack for because I believe that
I could add something significant to the
history of literature about 60% of me
believes that more or less by turns of
course these things don't have to be
mutually exclusive the vlogbrothers
self-actualize errs if there ever were
have raised millions of dollars for
charities through Kiva comm and the
project for awesome
last year $14,000 of that project for
awesome money went to kids in need of
desks in Malawi this year tens of
thousands of dollars is going to the
uncultured these things make a real
difference in the world but now I will
return to my videos in my writing Sean
will return to his hands-on work in
Bangladesh and though sat just inches
apart we are separated by a gulf of
experience a gulf of pain and suffering
and a sensory knowledge of privileges
that feel to me like mere facts a gulf
which i cannot cross let me go for which
many in Bangladesh
and to some extent me can never uncross
hey everybody thanks for watching thank
you so so here's the Evan Kat do one
take videos so maybe want to do this we
will be here for quite a while so if you
should check out his other videos you
will have annotations to various videos
but note on the world war you're seeing
us right now there'll be an annotation
to the uncultured project go there and
watch all of Sean's videos I admire
everything he does I think you know it's
absolutely incredible and I think you'll
think that to come here alright